next up every night across america
90 million people are up to the same
thing at night
it's snoring
either you or someone in your house is
playing that sweet nose music nightly
but how much can you take a study finds
a new survey found that the average
person can only stand it for about
90 minutes before they kick their
partner out of bed or i mean i'm
assuming probably move
you know to the couch or somewhere else
yeah i would does ross rossi do you or
welly snore how dare you i feel attacked
no
it's so funny when you said snore i was
looking at our audience and there were a
bunch of people here with their
significance and a lot of people went
like this
too late i'm looking at you
you know what are you gonna do
i don't know but someone in the audience
also deals with this dilemma yaffa are
you in our audience yaffa hi drew hey
what is your snore story oh
well my boyfriend snores so loud it
really makes me want to kick him to the
couch i love the guy i do
but a girl needs her beauty sleep too
yes what do you do
i end up on the couch
have you brought it up
well he's right here maybe bring it up
wait what how do you live through this
because
everyone's got to live through something
with someone so your thing is snoring
okay so now what do you do
so drew ross obviously i mean i think
i'm going to get in trouble when i get
home but yeah so the thing is i think
you're already
the idea is to get her out of the bed so
i can have the whole bed to myself
so
oh
you better be careful she might just be
out of that bed for good
does that are you faking it yeah it's
faking it
[Laughter]
sometimes you just want to like lay back
relax turn on netflix maybe watch a
movie on your own but seriously are you
serious are you messing with her um
obviously i'm messing with her gosh darn
you i really fell for that and i was
like oh no
don't do that don't oh my god i'm so
relieved okay so everything's okay
you're not being duplicitous
and we're not plotting your death on the
way home no of course not great well
this is good news
can you can you do an impression of how
bad the snoring is
do you want me to yes yeah yeah yeah
just show us something we have an idea
you owe it to me yeah
yeah
good luck you guys thank you guys thank
you you're welcome um okay next story
god that really gave me an anxiety
attack worried you hey drew next we have
a story um i i know you're going to love
do you guys remember having that big cd
collection back in the day well a writer
at rolling stone named rob sheffield he
just wrote a love letter to the cd last
year cd sales actually increased for the
first time in 17 years how well they say
mostly thanks to adele bts and taylor
swift but rob is hoping for a major cd
comeback
okay you guys have to look at what she's
doing over here
she's bringing out
she oh my god it's so heavy i'm not
kidding drew commits to a story
she brought in her cd
book you still have your cds
look it opened right up to de la soul
and are these alphabetized they are
alphabetized
and yeah every book i have a to z
i just have to say the most shocking
thing about this story is how well
organized your cd cds are because look
at the desk
and look at her cds barrymore i'm proud
of you they're very proud of everybody
[Music]
you